[Music]
billowing clouds of tear gas filled the
streets across the capital
anti-government protesters chased down
and smoked out by the police
every age group is involved in this
street battle the stinging gas
can't be avoided
this was a day promising revolution
against president
it was consistently and indiscriminately
stamped out
drive-by shootings by the police
continues
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where protest marches usually
form up
they try setting fires and building
barricades
but the security forces were having none
of it police units moved into the crowds
firing continuously tear gas rounds
handguns
and rifles
those are bullets being found
they're right around the corner from us
these guys keep going
daddy
[Music]
it's not difficult to see why people are
unhappy porto prince is a hell hole of
poverty
this is a functioning marketplace it's
hard to believe
the city looks like a battlefield in
parts it is
but these streets destroyed in a huge
earthquake a decade ago
haven't been rebuilt
the people say the president has failed
to do anything has overseen mass
corruption but worst of all
has allowed kidnapping for ransom to
grow into the country's biggest growth
business
communities are terrorized by kidnap
gangs
now they barricade themselves in
protecting themselves with machetes the
rich
and the poorest are all targets for the
kidnapping
and they blame the president in terms of
what happens if he doesn't leave
[Music]
especially in the united
a disorganized political opposition say
they will continue their moves to oust
the president
but each day this country already one of
the poorest in the world
is sliding into absolute anarchy
stuart ramsey sky news haiti